[Musique]
vous les avez forcément vu sur les
routes ou à proximité des grandes villes
de la région ces nouveaux bus aux
couleurs voyantes
il propose pour la première fois en
france des liaisons entre les grandes
villes trajet autrefois réservée aux
trains si le temps de parcours est long
ce qui séduit les voyageurs c'est le
prix
je dois commencer à la mifi le temps
passe vite tout est bien j'ai regardé le
même trajet en train est à peu près 30
euros là j'en ai pour pour cinq fois
moins c'est plus long après je préfère
prendre plus de temps et ils gagner sur
mon argent que l'inversé des tarifs
imbattables quelle que soit la distance
un nombre croissant de personnes
transportées avec près de 3 millions
d'utilisateurs avant l'été en france et
pourtant trouvé ces bus n'est pas si
facile
nous sommes à orléans à quelques
dizaines de mètres de la sortie
d'autoroute
ici aucun panneau aucun siège ni abri
pas tout à l'ethnique boutique drôle de
gare routière s'est cependant ici que
s'arrêtent les huit bus faut le savoir
quand même que c'est ici la rai c'est
indiqué c'est pas indiqué où il faut
demander faut demander autour de soi way
13 heures le bus pour paris arrive
quelques usagers attendent c'est la
nouveauté de ce type de transport tout
se fait exclusivement sur internet ou
son téléphone
réservation et envoi d'informations aux
clients noisette
si bon exactement juste une peine de
deux années
ces voyageurs ont payé en moyenne 9
euros pour un trajet d'une heure trente
environ
les bus sont tous récents propre avec le
wi fi des prises usb ou 220 volts
c'est grand confort
14h45 pas trop de bouchons aujourd'hui
le bus arrive sans encombre sur la
capitale bémol tout de même il n'y a que
cinq trajets par jour d'orléans vers
paris effectués par ouï bus une dizaine
toutes compagnies confondues
c'est beaucoup moins qu'en train mais à
l'arrivée les usagers sont satisfaits
je n'avais pas les moyens de prendre le
train j'ai pas l'habitude de voyager en
bus mais je les fais à l'étranger donc
j'ai cherché sur internet si on pouvait
le faire ici et il s'avère que oui vous
noté un nombre croissant de personnes
qui montent dans ces bus oui le bouche à
oreille a bien marché
les prestations qu'on fait ça donne les
marchés aussi ce bus est arrivé porte
d'orléans sur un simple parking là aussi
sans abri ni toilettes mais la compagnie
ouïe bus dispose d'autres points
d'arrêts et de départ sur la capitale et
voici le plus gros d'entre eux la gare
de paris bercy
oui bus filiale de la sncf revendique
400 emplois créés depuis septembre 2015
son activité a été multiplié par trois
en huit mois
comme vous pouvez le voir il ya de plus
en plus de monde sur sur nos quais donc
nous sommes en train de nous agrandir
nous sommes en train de construire un
local pour accueillir du public et
pouvoir vendre des
des billets pour offrir un meilleur
service aux clients parce qu'il y en a
de plus en plus soit à l'heure de pointe
les bus manque de place sur ses quais on
part dc pour toute la france
oui bus dessert une cinquantaine de
villes sur tout le pays l'entreprise
annoncé en début d'année vouloir
transporter 4 millions de personnes sur
les gens qui voyagent avec we bus sont
des gens qui majoritairement aurait
voyagé en covoiturage aurait voyagé en
voiture bourrée voyage éventuellement
avec une autre une autre compagnie de
bus et puis en général ils se disent
heureux il se décide en extrême dernière
minute et donc pourquoi vous voulez
avoir un trajet peu cher que vous
réservez quelques jours voir le jour
même du départ
ben oui bus c'est une très très bonne
solution et ça rentre absolument pas en
concurrence avec le train si on essaye
de voir le trafic qui avait en autocar
en france il ya un an c'était presque
pas mesurable tellement c'est est faible
là le trafic est en train d'exploser
c'est vrai qu'il ya plusieurs compagnies
mais il ya une attente des français qui
est extrêmement importante et donc
aujourd'hui plus que de la concurrence
je dirais que c'est plutôt le gâteau des
qui est en train de grossir et le nombre
de déplacements des français qui est en
train d'augmenter
il ya des voyages qui se font avec we
bus qui ce feu qui ne se serait pas fait
si oui bus n'avait pas été là il ya des
gens qui voyagent qui voyageait plus qui
voyagent ya des gens qui voyagent aussi
plus fréquemment mairie but ce n'est pas
la seule compagnie sur le marché
français loin de là nous voici à tour au
sein de l' agence easy lines
il s'agit d'une filiale d'eurolines
entreprise qui propose depuis près de 30
ans des voyages en bus dans toute
l'europe pour paris tous les jours
amélie part et le pari
à 12 heures pour les jours à 12 heures
oui arrivée paris 15h30 pour eurolines
il n'était donc pas question de rater
l'ouverture du marché national de
transport en bus comme orléans tours est
une ville de passage situé sur les
grands axes mais deux destinations que
l'on voit émerger ce sont les
destinations vers paris et vers lyon on
a une troisième vers nantes
on peut avoir bien sûr tour comme ville
étape parce que touré quand même une
ville de châteaux de la loire
donc c'est une destination france qui
est intéressante et
sinon oui on est on est quand même plus
une tour et quand même
ah c'est une destination parisienne de
paris ouais euh
vous savez c'est vraiment toute la
clientèle tourangelle qui peut être
cesser du jeune c'est de la famille
c'est une clientèle des clients
affinitaire céder ce sont des seniors
des jeunes seniors ou enfin voilà tous
les clients sont intéressés par ce mode
de transport
il s'agit surtout des clients que l'on
voyait autrefois dans les trains corail
mais qui désertent les tgv comme les
étudiants
il y en a trente mille à tour et la
compagnie l'a bien compris rendez vous à
quelques centaines de mètres de la gare
sncf sur ce parking là aussi très peu
d'indications pas toilettes ni de
boutiques
difficile de savoir que c'est d'ici que
partent les bus et pourtant c'est super
pratique
y'a juste afin de réserver et on reçoit
directement liés par mail donc c'est
vraiment l'idéal
there votre monde à paris je vais passer
un examen en fait et donc c'est utile de
prendre le bus alors basse et surtout
super rentable en fait donc en tant
qu'étudiante franchement ça rien à voir
le train en même le covoiturage c'est
mon chat oui bus easy lines flix bus ou
encore mega bus toutes ces compagnies
effectué le voyage pour paris en moyenne
16 trajets sont réalisés chaque jour aux
opérateurs confondus sur cette ligne
le prix moyen est donc de 9 euros en bus
soit moins cher que le covoiturage qui
propose ce trajet à 15 euros en moyenne
et encore moins cher que le ter qui
facture sans réduction ce trajet à 36
euros octobre 2014
emmanuel macron ministre de l'économie
annonce l'ouverture à la concurrence du
marché avec plusieurs idées en tête ont
une désenclaver le territoire
or toutes les lignes créées dans la
région sont calqués sur le réseau
ferroviaire ou autoroutiers voyons les
trajets proposés par les compagnies tour
se trouve sur une ligne reliant bordeaux
à paris
châteauroux sur un axe reliant toulouse
à paris et enfin bauges sur une ligne
allant de clermont à la capitale tous
ses trajets passe par orléans
mais par exemple la ville de chartres
n'est pas desservi pour le moment cette
volonté de mieux relier le territoire
est restée vaine mais le grand souhait
d' emmanuel macron était avant tout de
créer des emplois dix mille d'ici
quelques années
bienvenue chez gatineau à beaune la
rolande dans le loiret l'entreprise de
55 salariés créée en 2008 propose ses
services de transport scolaire ou de
touristes mais depuis quelques mois de
nouveaux bus ont fait leur apparition au
dépôt gatineau désormais sous traitant
d' easy lines met à disposition
chauffeur et autocars pour le trajet
paris saint brieuc prêt-à-porter y aller
ça nous a permis de recruter six
conducteurs à temps à temps complet pour
effectuer ses rotations journalières 300
sont sains joue pas en quoi c'est des
gens qui ont créé il faut des
compétences un peu plus pointu que pour
le transport scolaire mais de toute
manière oui ça ça les chances a fait
notre activité ça les intéresse vraiment
tous les bus exploiter ou presque ne
sont pas la propriété dit lines qui sous
traitent en masse et ne s'occupe que du
marketing et des réservations
nous sommes à la gare routière de paris
gallieni là d'où partent et arrivent
tous les bus easy lines sous traitance
lignes régulières ou saisonnière en
fonction des besoins
le marché vient d'ouvrir et les
compagnies restent prudentes
c'est un environnement concurrentiel
totalement privée on peut conserver des
lignes qu'on veut maintenant l'objectif
c'est bien d'être rentable à terme donc
on est surtout dans un mode observatoire
on teste on ouvre des lignes on
communique dessus on regarde un petit
peu l'appétence des des clients sur ses
lignes et on les fait évoluer les
compagnies qui resteront seront celles
qui auront les moyens de leur patience
le marché est en plein développement
mais pour le moment tous les opérateurs
n'ont pas atteint leur retour sur
investissement
on est convaincu qu'il a une demande
parce que c'est une vraie opportunité et
c'est une vraie alternative aux moyens
de transport maintenant elle va grandir
petit à petit la sur le marché avec
l'ensemble des concurrents
il ya une suroffre par rapport à la
demande c'est à dire qu'elle cette
demande n'existera pas complètement par
rapport à une sur up dans trois ans donc
il faut tenir
il faut faire des prix qui sont corrects
qui sont pertinents oui bus comme easy
lines ces compagnies se donne trois ans
pour être rentable cela se fera sans
doute au prix de suppression de lignes
les syndicats des transports craignent à
ce sujet des ententes incontrôlable
entre les compagnies ces compagnies ne
vont pas faire toutes les régions
choisiront des régions elles se mettront
d'accord entre elles intel fera t-elle
région intel telle région l'autre fera
t-elle région et on aura toujours ces
lignes mais ils vont se mettre d'accord
y'a rien qui les encadrent aujourd'hui
par un dispositif validé par le
gouvernement au ministère des transports
y'a rien 1300 emplois ont été créés en
france aujourd'hui c'est pour le moment
bien en dessous de l'objectif des 10000
mais ces emplois sont ils pérenne les
compagnies supporteront tel leurs
investissements en allemagne où la même
ouverture de marché a été effectuée il
ya trois ans deux compagnies ont jeté
l'épongé
à lviv totalement au dessus de leurs
moyens la problématique c'est qu'elles
se font entrer une forme de concurrence
aujourd'hui il ya des compagnies qui
vont proposer des parcours on a un euro
moins cher que sur les autres ou mette
un prix d'appel en dessous de la réalité
toutes les lignes ne pourront pas bien
évidemment être rentable et ça dépend
encore de la bonne intelligence de tous
les concurrents par rapport aux prix
actuellement on voit des prix qui sont
excessivement bas et qui n'ont pas de
sens c'est très bien que lorsqu'on va
faire un trajet à 1 euro c'est pas le
prix d'une bouteille d'eau de ce soit
dans un aéroport hughes a donc on sait
que les prix remontent
mais pour autant ils resteront de toute
façon systématiquement moins cher que la
voiture individuelle que le covoiturage
ou que le train tout comme l'apparition
du logo jeu chez les compagnies
aériennes six nouveaux bus ont un impact
sur les autres modes de transport
aujourd'hui difficilement mesurable la
cgt cheminots parle toutefois d'une
perte de 250 millions d'euros
chiffre d'affaires pour la sncf au
second semestre 2015
c'est des phases en fait l'objectif
c'est d'évoluer en fonction de la
demande dont ce qui est important c'est
vraiment d'adapter l'offre à la demande
l'avantagé du but c'est que c'est un
mode agile et il n'ya pas les
investissements qu'il peut y avoir dans
le ferroviaire
donc on peut affrété un bus on peut
mettre tendue sur des lignes régulières
et trois mois après changer d'horaire ou
rajouter des doublages au fur et à
mesure où la demande se crée c'est
vraiment un mode agir et qui va évoluer
maintenant le marché est à ses prémices
donc oui il y aura beaucoup plus de
demandes dans les années qui vont venir
[Musique]
la flexibilité c'est sans doute ce qui
permettra au marché d'être viable les
pistes sont envisagées pour rendre le
kharg rentable développer le voyage de
nuit est laissée par la sncf vendre des
produits à bord créer des partenariats
avec des aires d'autoroute faire payer
les bagages comme dans l'aviation low
cost la révolution des bus macro est
lente mais elle est en marche